Es ist Länderspielpause in der 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Wir wollen aber nach dem vierten Spieltag und dem Ende der Transferphase noch einmal einen Blick auf einige Vereine werfen. Und das mache ich jetzt mit Thomas Haufe vom Nur der FCM Podcast und Kevin Bublitz vom Paracast. Viel Spaß!
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor.
Und Augsburg ist open.
Kroffi ist zu kurz ab, der lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1 zu 0.
Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, willkommen zurück zur zweiten Ligatour quasi. Ich bin Eva-Lotta Bohle. Ich bin ein Teil des Hostteams für die Rasenfunk Ligatour zur zweiten Bundesliga der Männer. Und zu Beginn dieser Sendung darf ich mich erst mal sehr über euer Feedback zur ersten regulären Folge dieses neuen Formats bedanken. Es war ja auch durchaus gemischt und ich glaube, das spiegelt auch ganz gut wieder, dass wir eben uns erstmal so ein bisschen finden müssen mit diesem neuen Format. Auch ein bisschen gucken, wie funktioniert es am besten für unsere Gäste. Denn an denen liegt ja die Hauptaufgabe in diesen Sendungen. Und das ist meine perfekte Überleitung. Denn ich darf zwei weitere Mitglieder unseres All-Star-Teams vorstellen. Zum einen ist da Thomas Haufe vom Nur der FCM-Podcast. Hallo Thomas.
Du hast einen wichtigen Punkt vorher schon gesagt, bei den Trainern mit dem Ringsi-Korps, bei gestandenen Vereinen und so. Wie hat es das mit den Spielern gemacht? Hier sind so viele Spieler gekommen, die U-20 teilweise auch sind. VfL Bochum hat sehr krass verjüngt, was ja ein guter Ansatz so gesehen vielleicht ist. Aber ich bin bei dir, sie haben halt dann wirklich diese Last der Verantwortung oder der Erfahrung auf zwei, drei Schultern. Es sind vielleicht ein paar mehr. Aber zwei, drei Spieler hätte ich jetzt unter den Verpflichtungen, wie Soko Vogt. Und dann hört es bei mir schon fast auf. Strom vielleicht noch, wobei der aus Ulm kommt. Also es ist jetzt auch vielleicht nicht das Niveau, was du in Bochum hast, um direkt durchzustarten. Aber schwierig, sehr riskant. Sehr riskante Transferpolitik. Ist nicht der erste Absteiger, der so strauchelt nach dem Saisonstück. Das kann halt in acht Wochen irgendwann auch wieder ganz anders ausschlagen. Das ist einer der Kandidaten, wo ich deswegen nicht vorhin gesagt habe, wenn der erste Absteiger schlagen will, spiele ich am Anfang der Saison gegen sie, weil dann sind sie völlig noch da nieder. Ja, bin ich beide ja total auf Risiko gegangen, was die Transferpolitik angeht. Ja, spannend. Also da bin ich wirklich gespannt, wie sich das entwickelt. Zumal Kevin Vogt jetzt für mich auch nicht so der Player ist mit 33 aus Berlin von Union gekommen. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ja, und du hast gesagt, ein Trainer ist vielleicht auch da. Ja, quasi. Ist spekulativ. Aber ich glaube, sie haben sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr wenig Erfahrungen dazu geholt. Also vor allem Erfahrungen in diesem harten 2. Liga-Geschäft, was es immer noch ist, wo alles sehr eng beieinander ist und wo es halt nicht so ist, dass Münz da nicht gewinnen kann, sondern die können das dann halt einfach, weil sie mehr Erfahrung auf den Platz bringen in dem Moment und vielleicht besser zu einem gewachsen sind auch schon. Thomas, du wolltest aber was sagen.
Ja, ja, das ist halt auch ein, also ich finde, das ist auch ein krasser Punkt, was du sagst mit den Verpflichtungen. Also, wir haben jetzt den Alpha-Rupik da von Leverkusen geholt. Man ist ja gut und schön, dass da ein 19-jähriges, scheinbar 19-jähriges Rose-Talent da ist. Aber man sagt ja nicht ohne Grund, dass junge Spieler sich am besten entwickeln, wenn sie in einer gewachsenen Hierarchie spielen, wo du ältere Spieler hast, die dich so ein bisschen führen. Das sehe ich in Bochum auch überhaupt nicht. Da schmeißt man jetzt ein paar junge Spieler rein, in der Hoffnung, dass das funktioniert. Gut, jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, du hast mit Dieter Hecking jetzt einen Trainer. Ja, der hat halt auch alles schon gesehen. Also dem machst du ja jetzt grundsätzlich auch erstmal nichts vor. Also der kann dir natürlich als jugendspieler dahingehend auch helfen. Das ist, glaube ich, was anderes, als wenn da jetzt ein Markus Fieler in dieser Situation wäre oder auch ein Trainer von Paula Born oder das wäre eine ganz andere Situation, glaube ich. Von daher glaube ich schon, dass Dieter Hecking da auch eine positive Rolle spielen kann. Aber so ein junger Kerl muss das natürlich auch erstmal alles annehmen, da in der 2. Liga. Das ist ja schon ein bisschen was anderes als Senioren-Bundesliga. Und es ist schön, mit 19 dann da hinzukommen. Aber da reden wir doch von Senioren-Fußball, nicht mehr von Jugend-Fußball. Das ist schon ein kleiner Unterschied. Und ich finde das auch ein sehr riskanter Weg, den man an Bochum geht. Ich bin echt gespannt, wie das da weitergeht. Aber ich glaube schon, dass die mit Dieter Hecking einen Trainer haben, der das da aus dem Dreck rauszieht, bin ich von überzeugt.
Ja, ich glaube einfach, ich weiß halt nicht, weil ich glaube, da liegt halt so viel im Argen, weil man eben diesen Abstieg hinter sich hat. Und man wollte halt, ich glaube, die Fans wollten halt vor allem Chris Gamboa und Toto Lissia da auch eben einen würdigen Abschied erweisen. Ich meine, Lissia ist jetzt im Trainerstab auch drin. Der hatte jetzt gestern, glaube ich, sein Abschiedsspiel. Vielleicht manchmal kann sowas ja auch helfen, um einfach so ein Verein noch mal näher zusammenwachsen zu lassen, indem man irgendwie eine absolute Vereinslegende auch feiert. Aber ich habe halt einfach das Gefühl, da ist eben nicht erst seit Anfang der Saison, sondern schon viel länger was im Argen. Und das hat, glaube ich, damals schon fast mit Peter Zeidler angefangen, wenn man da mal so ein bisschen zurückguckt, wenn man da auf die Transfers schaut, die da auch schon immer nicht glatt liefen. Ich glaube, dass das einfach ein Problem ist, was schon länger wächst. Und also, ich meine, Kevin, wir sind beide Fans von Vereinen, die es eben mitgemacht haben, was mal nach so einem Bundesliga-Abstieg passieren kann. Wenn du eben nicht dich nach einer Hälfte der Saison irgendwie wieder fängst. Also beide abgestiegen und dann eben schon fast auch sogar aus unterschiedlichen Gründen mal gerade an der Regionalliga vorbei gekratcht. Also, wie gesagt, aus unterschiedlichen Gründen. Aber also, das ist eben kein Selbstläufer hinten raus. Und klar, da ist– ich bin hier niemand, der öffentlich Training, Trainerentlassung fährt. Aber ich habe halt von Anfang an nicht so komplett verstanden, warum man so voreilig schon gesagt hat, man macht mit ihm weiter, anstatt sich in der Sommerpause vielleicht einfach mal fünf Tage zu nehmen und zu diskutieren. Was ist denn wirklich der beste Weg, vielleicht sogar Fan-Vertreter dazu zu holen, ne? Also, ohne das jetzt überspitzen zu können.
Die da Hedwig auch in eine andere Rolle stellen können, einfach übergeordnet. Also, das wäre für mich noch ein… Aber Thomas mag recht haben. Es kann natürlich auch so eine Art Papa-Figur für junge Spieler sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob das heutzutage bei so ganz jungen Spielern noch zieht. Aber das hat zum Beispiel bei Steffen Baumgart super funktioniert. Der war… Denn Sven Michel hat ihn mal der Alte genannt. Da hat es funktioniert. Aber ja, es kann schon ein positiver Punkt sein. Lass sie mal jetzt irgendwie eins dieser Spiele, was sie jetzt gegen Günther verloren haben, gewinnen. Und zwar genau andersrum irgendwie. Last-minute oder was weiß ich, mit einem Tor des Monats. Dann kann das so Typen wie Rupprecht und Co. natürlich auch pushen. Dann kann so ein Trainer vielleicht auch nochmal die jungen Spieler auch quasi mit viel Erfahrung nochmal dazu bringen, dass sie konstanter werden. Ich bin bei dir, Eva, du hast es ja gesagt, sie wirken sehr unkonzent... Also so wäre auch, dass sie noch gar kein richtiges Spielsystem verinnerlicht haben, sagen wir es mal so, um ein bisschen fachlich zu sprechen. Es ist sehr ungefestigt, sehr, sehr locker. Läufst du hier, läufst du da, läufst du da, nicht läufst du dorthin. Und wer hat noch nicht und wer übernimmt jetzt? Und das ist nicht zweitliger Niveau. Ich glaube, Thomas, das, was du gesagt hast, das ist noch mal was anderes als im jenüren Bereich. Dann einfach.
Genau. Wer sonst noch mehr zum VfL-Buch rumlesen will, da habe ich auch noch mal einen Artikel verlinkt vom 1848-Blog. Die haben auch einen Podcast. Also da sonst rein hören und rein lesen wäre mein Tipp. Und sonst würde ich diese Folge jetzt abschließen noch mit einer Runde Housekeeping. Ihr kennt es, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich ausschließlich durch euch. Und wenn ihr mehr dazu wissen wollt, dann geht einfach auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr alles Wichtige auch zur Regustierung und wie man uns unterstützen kann. Stellvertretend geht der Dank heute an SGE Le Smou, Tortinator Danny Chilien– ich habe keine Ahnung, ob ich das richtig ausspreche– und Kevin. Sonst erscheint am Montagabend die Spieltags-Sendung zum ersten Spieltag in der Bundesliga der Frauen. Max spricht damit Miri Schel und Adriana Wehrens. Und jetzt kommen die absoluten Skills aus meinem Deutschkurs nicht. Es wird auch eine Sendung, wenn ihr das hört, hier zu den Länderspielen der Männer erschienen sein. Von heute Abend, in dem Sonntagsabend auf, nach dem Spiel gegen Nordirland, wird aufgenommen, soweit ich weiß. Und sonst ist Marc in zwei Wochen wieder hier zu hören, sage ich jetzt einfach mal. Dann dürft ihr mit ihm wieder Vorlieb nehmen. Mich hört ihr sonst am nächsten Sonntag wieder für die Spieltagsbesprechung bei den Männern. Und bevor ich meine Gäste verabschiede, noch eine letzte Empfehlung für, und zwar für ein brandaktuelles Statement des Dachverbands für Fan-Hilfen. Da gab es heute ein bundesweites Treffen gegen die zunehmende Kriminalisierung von Fußballfans, auch im Zuge von März. Aussagen zuletzt. Und da wurden folgende Forderungen eben auch auf diesem Treffen beschlossen. Also einmal, dass man generell einfach sämtliche Pläne des sogenannten Sicherheitsgipfels aus dem vergangenen Herbst aufgibt. Unter anderem eben auch, dass die Vereine ein öffentliches und unmissverständliches Zeichen gegen die Hetzejagden gegenüber ihren Fans setzen. Verbot von Schuss- und Sprühwaffen sowie tasern der Polizei in den Stadien. Und eben auch eine Weiterbildung von Polizeieinheiten durch Aufnahme von Pflichtmodul, Fan-Kultur und Grundrechte um Gottes Willen in der Polizeiausbildung. Und eben auch ein langfristiger Kulturwandel und Abbau des Feindbildfans. Ich habe euch das ganze Statement mal verlinkt. Finde ich generell auch ein immer wieder wichtiges Thema. Es gibt sicherlich Sachen, die kann man immer wieder ambivalent diskutieren. Aber ich glaube dennoch, es ist wichtig, dass man eben die Fan-Hilfen, die Fan-Projekte weiterhin unterstützt. Die machen nämlich an jedem Standort eigentlich einen brutal wichtigen Job. Und den darf man auf gar keinen Fall unterschätzen. Das ist noch mein Schluss-Pilotier am Ende. Jetzt will ich aber meinen Gästen danken, die hier trotz kleiner Anlaufschwierigkeiten gut durchgehalten haben. Zum einen danke an Thomas Haufe. Danke, dass du mal wieder dabei warst.
Ja, danke für die Einladung und schönen Abend noch.
Und natürlich auch großen Dank an Kevin Bublitz vom Pardakast. Schön, dass auch du, ich glaube, dein jetzt insgesamt sechstes Mal, wenn ich richtig nachgeguckt habe, dabei gewesen bist.
Danke schön.
Und gestern vierhundertstes Mal Pardakast.
Stellt euch vor, ich hätte Konfetti mitgebracht und wäre vorbereitet gewesen.
Und ich habe heute fast gar nicht über einen SCP gesprochen. Das ist das erste Mal hier gewesen.
Ja, komm mal, das ist Respekt, das ist wie bei mir. Also ich habe das Wort Aminia heute sehr wenig in den Mund genommen. Ich möchte, also…
Obwohl die eigentlich auch zu den Gewinnern der Transferperiode gewinnt.
Ja, das können andere Leute besprechen.
Ich glaube, bevor ich mich jetzt selber ins Aus noch reite zum Ende dieser Folge, freue ich mich weiterhin über euer Feedback oder wir freuen uns darüber. Schreibt ins Forum, was ihr darüber denkt oder in den sozialen Medien. Und sonst wünsche ich euch ganz viel Spaß mit dieser Woche. Am Wochenende ist dann endlich wieder 2. Liga Fußball. Bis dahin macht's gut, bleibt gesund. Tschüss!
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir freuen uns über ihre Unterstützung.
Du lernst ein bisschen Geschichte und dann werden sie sehen, Herr Reporter, wie sich das damals im Parlament entwickelt hat.